hello everyone first of all apologies
that i am presenting like this online uh
because of uh visa hassles that happened
at last minute so my name is gather and
so here's my talk about practical
synthetic data sets
and why did i remember the mythical
monster of frankensteins
is because we want our synthetic data
sets to be as real as possible we should
be able to fool the models or through
the analytics that we are doing on the
synthetic data sets and not have
villagers coming to a lab with
pitchforks and torches
so a little about myself
i am currently pursuing a doctoral in
advance data mining
and since my specialization is a
theoretical privacy i have been
researching uh in the field of practical
synthetic data sets as well
i am an active writer and you can look
up my writings on medium senses and open
mind
so i write about deep learning and
explainable ai
private data analytics and mlaps
and i would definitely be happy to
connect with you on linkedin
so starting with what questions brought
you here
so i would make the safe assumption that
we are not here to talk about the
mythical monster but about synthetic
data sets
so these are the four questions that i
would like to focus uh in this talk
so what are the types of synthetic data
sets and why do we need them
and once we have made a certain
synthetic data sets
then what are the metrics that are used
to measure that realness
and definitely how you can make
synthetic data sets of your own because
definitely you have requirements that
are very specific to your field and your
problems so based on how the synthetic
data sets are created or synthesized
there are three major types so the first
is the ones that are synthesized from a
real-life data
second is from assumptions
and third is a hybrid of synthesis from
real data and assumptions
so when we talk about synthesis from
real data we use generative models and
many very commonly we use gans for this
so we fit a model to the real life data
and then once it's fed it has sampled
the real-life data then we generate
synthetic data sets from the trained
model
so this is a very simple diagram that
shows the process
again uh real world data sets are right
click problems
they have missing values
the dimensionality could be large
and
there could be certain problems with the
data acquisition process that it
introduces errors or discrepancies in
the attribute values
so uh the synthesized data set would
also reflect those
ambiguities so what uh is done in
certain cases is that synthetic data
sets are created based on assumptions
so what are these assumptions
these assumptions are taken from
existing models
that have been trained and shared with
public
or they could be based on assumptions by
data analysts
so a persona or if your team is working
on uh customer behavior
and it needs to analyze and
build a model on that
so the customer behavior it is a very
volatile domain and it changes
throughout the year it is a very
time specific behavior
for instance sale of ugly sweaters
during christmas
so your team or the expert analyst in
your team they might have a good
knowledge about customer behavior
specifically for different times of the
year or across the years
so we can use their knowledge
some of the
examples are historical trends in
financial markets
since financial markets are extremely
volatile
and then statistical distribution of
human traffic in an area
so again it is a very dom it is a very
dynamic situation
and we cannot rely on real life data
sets we will have to go about capture
the data first and we need to be sure
about its integrity so rather than going
the more expensive path what we can do
is we can model
an assumption and then create data sets
from those
and where exactly does uh this synthesis
from assumptions help
when there is very limited real
historical data
or
we have an expert analyst on board
or if the situation is noble
so the recent years they had shown a
very noble situation of the pandemic
over 19 condemning
and initially
as i observed in my country
and maybe some of you also observed it
there was a taboo attached to uh getting
afflicted with government people would
do self-medication and try to hide their
speakers
and sometimes if the situation was sent
only then they sought medical help
so in that case some of the data it was
missing for the initial time
so such an old situation uh it wanted it
asked for data sets
but because of the taboo and the limited
access
there was a shortage on the required
data
and this greatly hindered research as
well
so in such cases synthesis from
assumptions can be greatly beneficial
and we have a mixture of synthesis from
the assumptions and real life data so
that you can zero in on your domain
specific requirements
so which one is the best for you
so we have these types of synthetic data
those generated from non-public
real-world data sets so the utility can
be quite high especially since they are
non-public
and how is the difference uh brought in
by real public data
real public data would be de-identified
it would have privacy provisions imposed
on it
so the utility could be greatly hindered
by that
then we can have an existing model or a
process which can use simulations to
generate the data sets
this again the utility of such data sets
would depend on how properly or how
truly the existing model had
sampled the data and then given the
output
then there are practical synthetic data
sets that are based on analyst knowledge
again this is dependent on that person's
knowledge
and how much they understood the
requirement as well as how much they are
expert in the domain then there are
generic assumptions like we talk about
customer behavior
over the span of a year
so
we might assume that ugly sweaters sell
a lot during christmas so that's one
assumption and i would like to generate
some synthetic data on that
so utility it could be very low because
my assumptions they could be biased
they could be too tightly coupled with
uh what my assumptions are
so why synthetic data sets
there are two main reasons that assured
in the popularity of synthetic data sets
first was efficient access to data
so as we all know uh data acquisition it
is uh very costly
it is dependent on people as well
sometimes people would promise that they
would answer your survey but they don't
we all know that
so definitely access to data and
secondly uh there are secondary purposes
to
data sets for instance uh if you had
collected health data for cancer
patients
and you had used it uh to drive your
medical research
now uh there arose a secondary purpose
of uh checking uh
hospital related logistics
so how do we need to decide on certain
facilities that need to be provided to
cancer patients
so that is the secondary purpose
and when we talk about such purposes
there are very stringent regulations
like hipaa
so hipaa uh it has uh put on very strict
registrations uh because any private
health information if it is identified
even by a single field for instance your
phone number or your email then it would
prohibit sharing of that data set
so this is a major hurdle uh for sharing
of the data sets
and therefore uh the answer was found in
synthetic data sets they were not seen
to be prone to such uh disclosures
and pretty much in sync with hipaa and
gdpr regulations important benefit of
synthetic data sets is that they enable
better analytics in certain cases where
data collection could be costly or
ethically restricted
for instance we want to drive analytics
on data specific to children or certain
ethnicities
who are not uh technically advanced
so they do not understand the
implication of sharing the data
while uh there are uh regulations that
specify uh how the individuals need to
be aware of what would be the
certain outcomes if they share the data
so in such cases it is better to go with
the safe option of synthesizing data
then annotation of real-world data can
also prove to be a costly process
especially if you need to employ a team
or a certain tool to achieve that
uh then uh synthetic data has also
proven to be of uh great use when we do
proxy analysis
of uh to check the feasibility of a
certain model for analytics
so to save on the cost of data
acquisition first a certain test and
proxy tests can be done
through synthesized data
and if the models are found to be
performing well then we can go ahead and
allocate budget for data acquisition
so there are some specific domains that
greatly benefit from synthetic data
when we come to manufacturing and
distribution
now we have robots that are being
powered by aiml
uh they do this location and picking of
objects that are
in different positions and stacked up
differently
so a very popular example is the amazon
picking challenge
where they pit teams against each other
to devise complex models
where the models have been trained to
detect different permutations of
positions
they should be able to handle different
lighting scenarios
so rather than using people to carry out
all these permutations it makes sense to
synthesize such images
so this is one example image it's a
synthetic image of domino's placement
that was uh simulated by nvidia graphics
rendering engine so rather than having
someone please dominoes and all these uh
inexhaustible combinations of domino's
pieces
we have this engine that is quickly
generating images for you
healthcare definitely has gained a lot
from synthetic data because uh
individual uh information is a very
critical and demands legality
so all these uh requirements uh they
cause a lot of cost intensive operations
like previously provisions
and de-identification
so
based on the sensitivity of afflictions
and all the information that we need to
have individuals of individuals
we should go for synthesis in those
cases
additionally uh some medical data sets
can be complex
like images so for instance we have
retinal images data set and now the team
wants to do an analysis for diabetic
retinopathy
so in this case rather than going around
and
approaching diabetic patients and then
checking if they are willing to share
the images of the retinas going through
all those tests it is better if we
synthesize such images from existing
retinal images add some clouding and the
problems that are typical of the
affliction
a synthetic cancer registry being
maintained by public health england is
one very
commonly available cancer individual
data that you can check out in the link
then in some cases we need to do a rapid
evaluation of a technology
for instance cambridge uh cement takes a
boston-based firm they created a graph
database for healthcare cases
and they wanted to check how the this
pilot project would work before starting
a actual data acquisition so they use
synthesized data to check the
performance of this pilot and once the
performance was found to be promising
they went ahead with data collection
when we come to financial services again
uh there is a major need for privacy
provisions
and the historical market data is vast
and it is it could be extensive based on
the access restrictions that have been
placed by the custodians and the owners
so uh and
there are benchmarking uh requirements
as well
so we have a risk modeling software and
hardware that need to be evaluated
for the real-time performance
so stack a to benchmark you can check
out the link the this is being used to
benchmark the performance of such uh
modeling software
when we come to transportation a very
interesting use case is self-driving
cars that are being driven by ai ml
so these models they are trained and
tested on images that were captured from
lidar sensors and cameras mounted on top
of cars and those cars they were driven
around a certain area
so you see the problem that the
geography is restrictive it is very
typical of this that place and the
driving and walking behavior of people
of that area
so uh again we are going by the
assumption that all roads and all
driving conditions would be similar to
what had been recorded which is
definitely not the case so what we can
do is synthesize uh further images for a
different topography and different
driving behaviors
to test out these autonomous uh driving
solutions
and hackathons and data phones that are
i think many of you must have taken part
in it so again to circumvent legality
and privacy provisions and the cost of
acquisition these hackathons they
sometimes rely on synthetic data sets
to pose a problem and host these events
so how do we measure the realness of
these frankenstein datasets you created
a frankenstein and you wanted to mix in
with the real world without uh having
villagers knocking on your door and
coming with their pitchforks and torches
so what do we do we use some metrics to
check how nicely a synthesized data is
following its seed
there are four ways of comparing the
statistics uh let's start with the
univariate
statistics so uh we plot the trends
followed by one feature between the real
and the synthetic data sets uh if we go
by the looks of it the left one is a
very good case now the synthetic data
and real data pretty much in sync while
the right one is at a chaos
you want to ask the model what they were
thinking
but pictures are again not everything we
need to put numbers to these metrics
so what we do is we compute helena
distance
which is the measure of probability
and it indicates whether there is a
difference between the two distributions
of one variable
so uh it's a probabilistic measure so
that means that the differences have
been scaled between the values 0 and 1
coming to bivariate statistics
comparison we take pairs of variables
between the two data sets under
comparison and it is definitely driven
by the type of variables that we have
under consideration so if we have a
continuous variable pair we go for pairs
and coefficient if the pair involves
continuous and nominal variables then we
go for multiple correlation coefficient
and so on
once you have uh computed the
correlations you can again plot a heat
map of the computed values
here we see the problem typical of
synthesizing from real-world data sets
so while lighter shades the ones tending
to white they show great promise that
the synthesized data was close to the
real one
but all those gray boxes they show that
correlation could not be computed
because of missing values or
low variability offered by the feature
so when comparing multivariate
statistics uh we are playing the game of
your eight
so what we are doing is we take each
feature we say you are eight
and what does that it means it is the
target variable
that the classification model would try
to find or output
so it is a very exhaustive process
because we are going through each
feature and making it the target
variable for that run
uh we can definitely boost the
performance through gbms
uh but again it is quite exhaustive and
computation heavy
next we come to distinguishability
so what distinguishability are we aiming
at the distinguishability between
a particular observation that belongs to
a real record or the synthesized record
so what we do is we build a binary
classification model
and what is the target variable
target variable is a new field which
could be zero or one that we assigned to
each observation of the data sets
so if it's a observation of a real
record
it will have an extra variable assigned
with a value of one
and if it's a synthesized record the
observation would have this new value
zero and these are these records with
this extra variable they would be used
to train and test the binary
classification model
the intent is to check whether the
classification model can find uh or it
can predict properly if a particular
observation belong to a real record or a
synthetic record
so for this a metric we use the value of
propensity score which is the
probability of each of the prediction
so in this case we had assigned one for
a real record so propensity score which
tends to one means that the observation
belongs to the real record
and we can definitely do the assignment
and vice versa also
so then you have to be careful how you
watch this propensity square
propensity is four
so great we know the basics of synthetic
data sets you want to get started you
want to make synthetic data sets of your
own based on what problem you have at
hand so
uh so pi db gen is a very popular uh
library that you can use to create uh er
databases
it is data frame friendly so what
database you create can be easily read
through pandas data frame and you can do
the further processing
under the hood it's using faker which is
also very popular library
you can fill in the fake data in your
data sets if they are missing values and
you can definitely use speaker on its
own as well to create your data set
and then you might have scenario
specific requirements for instance you
want to simulate a music streaming event
which had different genres
and different kinds of
individuals who were part of that event
where different age groups and genders
and their preference for specific genres
so such uh short-term scenarios they can
be synthesized using true media
it is a very exciting library in fact uh
you can also simulate customer behavior
for a specific period of time
so just to see that how uh if you want
to simulate how people buy certain uh
item
during the first three months of the
year or during the middle of the year so
true mania is definitely the library to
use
then we have data data synthesizer which
provides a web-based user interface
where you can synthesize a new data set
additionally you can add differential
privacy to the c data set the real one
and then go on with the synthesis
so you will be working on a private uh
real data set and synthesizing from it
which is a very good thing to do
especially if you are working on
critical data sets then you can create
regression and classification specific
data sets as well using senpai
so when we talk about synthetic data it
is a development environment rather than
a library as such you will get the
environment conducive to creation of
gans and distribution functions that you
can further use for data synthesis
uh definitely time series is one kind of
data that you would want to synthesize
at some point so nike's time series
generator is a very popular way to go
about it
so great uh let's capture some lightning
and create our frankenstein
so i have this piece of code where we
are using numpy and scikit learn to
create
some synthetic data
this the link to this
notebook has been shared in the ppt as
well if we would be sharing it further
after the presentation
so definitely the setup requires uh
import of certain libraries
this is the seat value 11. you can go
about it and play with received value
so first we would synthesize univariate
distributions
of different types like uniform normal
exponential log normal chi-square and
beta so these are the different
distributions on this is fake data
coming to specific requirement of
classification but i want a synthetic
data set for a classifier
so for this psychic learn has these
functions
it has me classification
make classification function has this
parameter class step which specifies
what would be the spread of the
classes the target variables
so
we have two features
class step is of different values point
one one and ten
we'll be generating a thousand samples
and these are the three plots for
different spreads
so for point one you can see the two
classes are pretty much overlapping
with classic one there is a little
difference and with classic 10 they are
very glue demarcated
now we'll come to a multi-label
classification where we want more than
two classes
so again now this function is make
multi-label classification where again
you can specify the number of features
the number of observations
and labels
my labels have kept as number only
number of classes here is 4.
so for different labels
we have these
plots
so similarly scikit learn can be used to
generate data sets for regression as
well as clustering problems
so this is all for today's talk
i have curated the sources as well for
you that i have kept at the end of the
slide
and if the bbts are shared then these uh
resources can be used by you
for the knowledge
so thank you for your time and i hope
that you could take something new from
here
and looking forward to your feedback and
questions
thank you
[Applause]
all right
gaza can you hear us can you hear me
yeah awesome yes all right cool um i'm
gonna read a couple of questions that
came in on slido um the topmost is uh
have you considered couplers for
modeling testing for equality of
multivariate dependencies
oh sorry i didn't get a question have
you considered
a group class
coppola's thorium if i pronounce this
incorrect
uh
have you considered copulas for modeling
testing of equality of multivariate
dependencies
uh no i have not okay okay
next question is um how do you preserve
the connection between the label and the
features as well as the joint
distribution of the features in the
synthetic data set
okay
so uh
this is pretty much a characteristic of
how we are synthesizing from the seed
data so the libraries that they are
using they are preserving these
relationships between the features and
the distributions
all right thank you very much and the
last question is how would you approach
showing a realness in synthetically
generated image data
okay so in images uh there was this
research that i read in which uh
we
also modeled uh another
like shadow adversary kind of model uh
that was also checking um the
classification of the images so we have
the main uh synthesized images uh the
main classification classification model
and one shadow adversary that was
checking how well it would uh
identify the fake and the real images
okay
and another question besides being
distinguishable do you have
recommendations for other metrics that
measure the level of privacy gained over
the real data
okay the previously provisions
uh see uh synthetic data sets they are
definitely uh prone to uh disclosures as
well
so the privacy measures uh if you have
to mark them against the utility
entropy can definitely be computed for
that
we have to be very mindful that utility
is not disturbed if we are enforcing
privacy as well
so uh my suggestion would be starting
with privatized data sets
the seeds that we are using and then
carry out synthesis on them
awesome
and in your experience does a model
trained with synthetic data instead of
real data lose accuracy
i used one sorry if it loses accuracy
uh so the intent is that we need to fool
the model
so um
what i have i have run some pieces of
code i've trained a model that used a
combination of real data fake data
and
the metric used was rmse
and i
achieved pretty good results
in terms of very low rmses uh with that
combination i said
all right okay
that would be all questions if there's
no more questions for the room
then that's a wrap thank you all very
much